those two feelings I think one is
hopeful and two I think might be the
first time in the show where we've
actually felt the insecure caste dishing
on how fans will feel after watching the
season 3 finale I feel like the season
finale may bring back some Coachella
flashbacks is that true we can't go into
any details but I do you think one of
the fun things about events like
Coachella in real life sometimes the
consequences of those events live on and
so you have to face face realities we
were I having done some things and so as
the pretty suggestive you'll see some of
us are still dealing with the aftermath
the aftermath of Nance for ghosting I
hope that that's address Nathan I'll be
passed I'll be pressed you're not
pressed for three insecure characters
for three people who are battling
insecurities you know between ISA Molly
and Lawrence I think it's gonna be the
first time where we might actually feel
a sense of calm because we've never seen
that on the show before we've never seen
the three of these characters right in a
very in a peaceful place everything is
always hiding chaotic and crazy and
crazy to some degree at night I want to
seek out and crazy but it's definitely
there experiencing the highs and lows of
life right and everything in between
[Music]
but we have the amazing regina king who
directed the season finale talk to me
about how she really guided this entire
project
it was incredible so this is my gonna be
my first written by episode so it's me
and ISA co-wrote the episode yeah and it
was directed by Regina watching her work
was a masterclass so I feel really
fortunate enough to have my my sort of
first episode of the series during
Regina remember when she first met me we
like talked 10 minutes later she comes
up to me and she's just like you are not
Kelly
you are so dead like she was just like
she's like that is just I'm so impressed
by you
if that was my entrance into working
with her and from that point on I felt
like a little bit at ease around her
it's like super nervous as season 3
comes to a close the cast already has
season 4 on the brain we watched Orion
take the lead on this case along with
you go higher I think Molly is still
shell-shocked because she's not leaving
the wife room would give her some kind
of like freedom to be herself but now
she's finding like well what made me
special there no longer applies here so
now I got it like hustling I'm not gonna
be taking advantage it's like when you
go from one bad relationship and like
you go to a good relationship but you
don't know how to like allow yourself to
be loved in a good way yeah so you're
like well nah cuz my old boyfriends like
don't ya what we got because you met at
somebody else that's not here don't
bring in the baggage the bag lady you
gonna miss your blessing Molly
exactly and so I think I think she's
gonna learn some some interesting
lessons and and I think she's gonna
there's gonna be some maybe not so good
things to come from that but how she
bounces back still remains the easy
hey speaking of ISA and Molly what
advice do you have for them with their
dating life I think Molly needs to get
out of her own way I think she's a self
saboteur great and I think ISA has a
hard time of letting go so I think one
needs to sort of let go when it needs to
get free so let's hope they do that and
I'm at your home to let someone get free
as Kelly who's best for ISA I want
Moritz to come back in a very because I
feel like they didn't break mutually
like circumstance required that you know
they break up but I just wonder what
would happen if they left knowing that
that they tried everything what have you
been up to what does it look like if
they find a baseline and can they keep
it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]